the opening scene features a beautiful
but Ultra religious planet called Argos
here we are introduced to a man by the
name of alekos who is fervently praying
to a statue of the God pilopes in the
midst of his prayers the lights suddenly
begin to Flicker and a group of soldiers
called SG-1 materialized there they have
actually teleported from Earth to
research the planet the team consists of
four members Colonel Jack O'Neill Dr
Daniel Jackson Captain Samantha Carter
and TLC upon noticing their arrival
alekos quickly hides behind the statue
believing that they are Gods he is too
scared to confront them at the moment
but shortly after the team discovers him
along with his pregnant wife thatis who
is already in labor everyone looks at
Samantha the only woman in the group
hoping that she can assist with the
delivery however she sadly admits that
she has no experience with childbirth
with no options left Dr Daniel steps in
and takes charge of the situation using
his knowledge learned from books he
successfully helps theatis give birth
which brings immense happiness to the
parents in appreciate appreciation they
invite the team to their village where a
grand celebration is in full swing to
the group's surprise all the people of
Argos are extremely good looking with
exemplary features amidst the
festivities a young woman named kinthia
catches the eye of Colonel Jack O'Neill
as she appears to be smitten with him
kinthia offers Jack A peculiar cake
which she consumes alone and starts
hallucinating she then proceeds to
perform an elaborate dance for Jack
before taking him to her bed chamber ah
these aliens know how to party while the
two are getting intimate the other
villagers abruptly enter the room and
inexplicably fall unconscious even Jack
who seems to have just snapped out of
the intoxication is left baffled by the
occurrence before too long he loses his
Consciousness like the other villagers
Samantha upon observing the strange
incident deduces that there may be
something in the argosian's diet
particularly the food that was offered
exclusively to Jack which caused him to
pass out alongside the natives as soon
as the sun rises the entire Village as
well as Jack awakens at exactly the same
time as if it were a customary
occurrence for the argosian people
however the soldiers are left in utter
disbelief when they realize that the
baby they delivered the day prior is now
walking around as if he were a
one-year-old child puzzled by the
abnormality SG-1 delves into the matter
and discovers that the inhabitants of
Argos possess an incredibly short life
span of only 100 days remarkably an
entire human lifespan is compressed into
this brief period causing them to age at
an accelerated rate maybe they should
stop partying so much upon making this
discovery SG-1 is struck by a sudden
realization that Jack who had physical
contact with kynthia the previous
evening has also been affected by this
phenomenon so now they will have to
quickly unravel the mystery behind this
peculiar trait and save their friend
before it's too late later as the group
is looking for Clues inside the temple
they stumble upon an ancient script
inscribed at the base of pilops's statue
it shockingly discloses that the
argosians are part of an experiment
conducted by pilafs the so-called
ancient Greek hero it turns out that he
had an interest in Humanity's
evolutionary development and shows the
argosians as subjects for his experiment
through a virus that he had introduced
into their blood cells pilops caused the
argosians to age at an incredibly rapid
rate as the team delves deeper into the
matter they discover that pilops left
the planet before his work was complete
leaving the argosians to face the
consequences of his experiments later
that day Colonel Jack orders the rest of
the team to retrieve blood samples from
him and the natives to conduct further
analysis on Earth they are a bit
hesitant to leave him alone but when he
assures them that he'll be fine they
agree after reaching the Stargate lab on
Earth Samantha along with a lab expert
conducts numerous tests on the blood
samples and eventually discovers the
presence of Nano machines which are
responsible for the accelerated aging
process after this Samantha returns to
the argosian planet where she finds Jack
in a much older and fragile state than
before this makes her realize that he is
aging much faster than the other
argosians because the virus is
compensating for the 40-something years
he has already lived Jack has received
an STD known as nanoria based on her
calculations she predicts that Jack will
die within just a few weeks fearing for
his life Samantha urges him to accompany
her back to the Stargate headquarters on
Earth for treatment but he refuses
saying that he cannot risk the lives of
other people there instead Colonel Jack
orders his team to return to Earth and
work on finding a cure for the virus in
hopes of saving his life in the
following days his rapid aging continues
to take a toll on him causing him to
transform into an irritable and grumpy
old man complete with gray hairs and
wrinkles as well as an inability to
figure out how email works Jack is
frustrated by his new situation and
vents his anger on the visitors who come
to the temple despite his struggles he
attempts to write a letter to his
ex-wife Sarah but fails to find the
right words after only writing dear
Sarah one day kinthia pays Jack a visit
and he starts to open up about their
situation he explains that in reality
humans age at a much slower rate than
they do and that the average life
expectancy is around 70 years
furthermore he reveals that the
argosian's supposed Greek god pilafs has
been using them for his own experiment
the Revelation shockskinthia but at the
same time she is happy that the truth
has been revealed after this the two
kiss passionately to drown their sorrows
I'd argue that Jack is still getting a
better deal than most humans in the lab
at Stargate Labs on Earth Samantha
investigates the molecular makeup of the
argosian's blood samples and discovers
tiny transmitter-like machines called
Nano machines that use atomic particles
to self-replicate during the course of
the study Samantha's protective gloves
are eaten Away by the Nano machines but
she is able to remove them before any
harm is done to her hands following this
Major General Hammond puts a stop to all
experiments and travels to and from the
Argos Planet until further notice in
order to mitigate its risk despite the
team's efforts to convince him and
otherwise arguing that they cannot
abandon Jack to his Fates he stands by
his decision this news is disheartening
for Jack and the team sends him a
farewell video message expressing their
regret that they cannot do anything for
him now Jack sends back a video message
of his own saying he did it all for the
nookie in the next scene the argosians
make a desperate plea to peel off his
statue to return much to Jack's dismay
he becomes furious at the villagers for
still believing in pilops and proceeds
to shout at them he then delivers a pep
speech persuading them that their
so-called Greek God won't come back and
cannot harm them either Jack further
says that pilop seized thousands of
Precious Years from their lives making
them a victim of his experiment this
finally convinces the argosians and they
break down the statue to overcome their
fear of death following this Jack and
kenthia decide to take a stroll along
the beach that is located far away from
their Village eventually they reach the
borderline which had previously been
forbidden by pilops to cross it despite
kinthia's initial hesitation Jack
persuades to ignore pilop's restrictions
since his words are no longer relevant
thus the duo crosses the boundary line
and they continue to walk along the
beach after walking for some time the
pair decides to light a campfire and
engage in a conversation as the night
progresses they realize that they have
not fallen asleep yet despite the late
hour poor kynthia believes that they are
being punished but Jack assumes that
their sleep cycle is probably dependent
on some kind of transmitter and they are
currently out of its range after a bit
of thinking he comes to the conclusion
that the argosian's entire way of life
and behavior may have been influenced
and dictated by this transmitter the
following morning Jack and kynthia
embark on their return Journey to the
Village however when they arrive they
notice that all of the other villagers
are still sleeping Jack becomes
suspicious and decides to investigate
the cause of their prolonged sleep he
starts to search for the transmitter
which he believes is responsible for
altering sleep cycles of the villagers
and after hours of searching he
eventually finds it hidden among the
ruins of pilops's statue elated by the
discovery Jack hurriedly summons the
rest of his team members to examine it
as soon as they arrive they analyze the
transmitter and to discover that it
operates on two different frequencies
one puts the villagers to sleep and
activates the Nano machines while the
other frequency shuts everything off for
the day the team concludes that the
villagers must have damaged the wake-up
call frequency during their Rebellion
against pilaf's statue which resulted in
their prolonged sleep without any
further delay the team then deactivates
the Sleep frequency of the transmitter
which immediately awakens all the
Sleeping villagers in the aftermath of
their Discovery and deactivation of the
transmitters SG-1 team members speculate
on the potential effects on the body
they hypothesize that without the
constant influx of new Nano machines the
villager's immune systems will now be
able to identify and attack the
non-functioning Nano machines in their
blood cells this means that the
argosians will age at a normal rate
going forward furthermore Samantha
predicts that Jack whose body was
altered by the Nano machines will
eventually return to his original state
within a weeks as the deactivated Nano
machines can no longer manipulate his
blood cells in the final scene we are
shown a heartwarming conversation
between Jack and Cynthia as the time has
come for the colonel to depart the two
lovers speak of their mutual feelings
and the future that lies ahead Jack with
a heavy heart assures kinthia that he
will send his soldiers to check on her
regularly so that she doesn't feel alone
Jack himself won't be back though
because he is a puck boy he expresses
his gratitude to her for teaching him
valuable lessons about life love and the
importance of enjoying every moment the
movie ends as they Bid Farewell to one
another promising to me soon
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching